my thirst for success just comes from
being born in New York and just one to
do all the things I dreamed about my
goal was to be the best to change the
game of your DJ be a DJ if you're a
radio personality be a radio personality
and nothing more I don't believe in
doing anything halfway I believe in
going all the way he's an American hip
hop recording artist record producer
actor and entrepreneur he's released
eight consecutive platinum and
multi-platinum albums he's often named
as one of the world's greatest hip-hop
artists he's nas and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite I
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips as
always if he says something that really
resonates with you please also leave it
in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well let those for success
this comes from being born in New York
and just one to do all the things I
dreamed about I always had some kind of
drive and
but I was going to be screenplay writer
know whether I was going to be artists
that Illustrated comic books I wanted to
be a businessman it set up my room like
an office when I was like ten years old
whatever I got into always plan to excel
I always believed that I could have it I
always believed that I could give people
my ideas to our live with barbeque was
the first time you were ever on a song
what was that like when you first heard
that when I first heard live at the
barbecue on radio I was just walking
through my neighborhood and I saw a
bunch of older guys it was late night as
I walked by I hit a song and I'm like
wow I'm telling some of the guys that's
me but you know the older faded day
after we listened it to me sort of like
yeah okay cool when they going back to
the conversation they're not listening
but it didn't matter
I heard me that walked back to my block
I was sort of in a daze like it's
happening
okay it's happening I'm in rap now I'm
I'm a part of this rap thing that was my
dream just that
so I'm like hi this is perfect
this is actually perfect I've opened the
door the door has open for me to have a
chance to be heard and I will be a name
known in this great thing called rap my
goal was to be the best to change the
game I realized I could do that at that
point I said nah no one could tell me
anything now I got it I know what it
takes I got what it takes and what I'm
telling artists is you got to have balls
they got to let these guys know if
you're a DJ be a DJ if you're a radio
personality be a radio personality and
nothing more we make the music that
allows them to have a voice on a radio
and they took control and try to say say
that they have all the power and going
to dictate what we have to do I spoke
out against it so they got a dummy to go
up there and be a dummy on the radio and
speak on their behalf and talk about me
and this is really unfortunate because
they using them and he's not even a part
of my fight my fight is a big fight my
fight is against any power structure
that's going to try to hold back freedom
of speech and I fight ain't over yet my
advice for the young adores would be you
know push yourself all away don't obsess
over what anybody else is doing
if you have given opportunity and you're
lucky enough to have freedom to do what
you want to do on your career while I
trap yourself why do something that's
not you around Nostradamus I wasn't
motivated like I was before he was gone
Park was gone I didn't see a reason to
keep making music at that time I needed
some time off you get him right like a
new beginning as a new beginning of real
silly
today I have a great appreciation for
those people out there that got me here
today for the experience I had a journey
that I had I wish you'd acknowledge
something you know this is some of you
may know somebody may not a lot of your
young this brother right here his name
is lost professor this brother right
here
started a food poor base sauce early
nineties this brother right here think
about be enough to give a 60 year old
kid a shot at a studio it put me on that
song laugh at the barbecue this is my
dude I feel like I can stop now
and I'm totally satisfied but I'm really
happy that is this some burning and you
still to put out more I love music hip
hop music singing whatever I love music
that's telling me that's dead burns in
me rest is history
can you campaign
I love you never stop never show ya what
free you means never settling it's like
wanting to be the best at whatever you
do never stop it to you the best like I
don't believe in doing anything halfway
I believe in going all the way so we
gotta stop growing up in Queensbridge
hip hop was the most amazing thing I
ever heard
there was nothing more important to me
in the whole world then having a voice I
wanted to make a big impact on this
artform I wanted to kick everybody out I
wanted to open up a doorway for another
generation one thing I don't ever want
to be as mainstream my goal is to not be
what the mainstream calls a legend I
just want to do what I do
legends a big big title
oh there's enough legends out there you
know I mean I'm just I'm just living how
it feel to know you timeless you're
forever every time you touch that mic
every time you do a concert a show a
club and you know you can perform your
catalogue and it still feel brand-new
and if you didn't want to make another
record you're forever relevant it's
important because there's a lot of
artists only can make one record can you
make an album or make it past the first
out this is a special blessing you know
I mean this that this rest a special
cloth alert this is what I'm talking
about in saying I got you yo is is you
for nice it's wrong word is
I don't have the word for it is um I'm
grateful most of all because I'm just a
fan I'm uh I'm a fan of the music and
the art form so that's all I want to be
as a fan if I come out to the stage if I
show up with the records and and not
many people show up with me I get it
it's not it's not her I don't have to
you know one owes me anything
I appreciate people's ears and that's it
so if I get I just go with the feeling
and go with the vibe and um and whatever
happens you know it's a learning
experience and then you come back again
stronger but um every time I'm out there
I never know if who's gonna show up
hello somebody there don't worry about
it
just go to sleep who is that it's Naz
met you at the party earlier wait where
are you
maybe I'm on the curtains maybe I'm a
new wardrobe behind ironing board
maybe I'm right behind you I wanted to
charge myself
notice we had the same phone I figured
you'd have the charger so I stole your
room King stole my key knock knock who's
there
hello Joe plan just trying to buy time
to charge my phone where are you I
should have left that fifty percent but
I always like to leave with a full power
bar I'm not gonna go to sleep until you
leave the room I'm good I don't know
what that means when you just say I'm
good
that doesn't mean any little baby don't
say now just gonna buy you a brand new
I'm not live you got a go pal guess you
don't like lullabies where are you
really doesn't matter just go back to
sleep
where the [ __ ] are you I'm in shadows
there are no shadows there's always a
shadow where are you
I was never had you've anybody cellto
time
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because spikes
21:08 asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of the 10
rules had the biggest impact on you and
why what are you going to apply to your
life or business leave in the comments
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon
don't feel when you're offstage in
general how's your self-esteem did you
feel like you need to be saying those
things to feel like you're pumped up and
ready to go no I mean you know I when
I'm on stage I puff up I've become I
become I embody everything my music is
once I walk off I'm chilling yeah what
up this is NAS and this is like a crazy
party and crazy day I remember back in
the days I went to a party in the city
for the shaft movie premiere with Samuel
Jackson New York City nightclub all of a
sudden I'm in the middle of Wesley
Snipes and Grace Jones Wesley had on
black he was chilling and and grace was
children very beautiful Grace Jones
knocked my drink on my arm some of you
got on her arm she didn't see me there
she just did it by mistake and I looked
she looked at me she grabbed her arm
they were sleeveless she looked at her
arm where the drink had fell and just
licked her on what a drink I felt and I
was a few thing I was starstruck yawning
I thought I was in the twilight zone
she probably didn't even know who I was
oh she is I'm a fan and someone else
grab him this Wesley Snipes oh [ __ ] he
pushed boom and he's asked me are you a
rapper or scientist so I did my hair
Wesley Snipes would be kind of hard like
that's Wesley and everything but you
know he's pushing me like what's going
on I said are you a rapper a scientist
and I'm like damn Wesley Snipes is about
to do so blade
so I pushed it back on and I said you
won't make it out of here live
Wesley realized why am i pushing knives
and I'm like why am i pushing back
Wesley and where's Grace Jones at it was
just a weird little moment like this and
that was some crazy-ass [ __ ] back in the
days around away loved those days